[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce 3 mai 2022 dans
les yvelines la campagne pour la
municipale partielle bat son plein à
mantes-la-jolie sur fond de tensions
entre le maire démissionnaire qui se
représente avec une nouvelle équipe face
notamment à ses anciens colistiers
soutenu par le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines nous faisons
un premier point sur les candidatures
une campagne en chasse une autre et les
législatives se dérouleront les 12 et 19
juin les républicains viennent de
dévoiler la liste de leurs candidats
dans les yvelines un département où ils
tenteront de faire mentir la tendance
nationale est de conserver à minima lors
de postes et puis c'est une première une
femme vient d'être nommé enfin à la tête
du trianon palace à versailles le
prestigieux hôtel accueille à sa tête
stéphanie rimbaud son portrait à suivre
[Musique]
les mantes et les mantais sont appelés à
élire leur nouveau conseil municipal un
scrutin le 15 mai prochain après la
démission du maire raphaël cogner en
janvier dernier une démission suite à
des divisions au sein de la majorité
mais le maire démissionnaire sera
candidat pour partir sur un nouveau
projet qu'on a fait avec mon équipe un
certain nombre de panneaux par thèmes et
les gens qui rentrent nous
notes des post it et nous disent des
propositions ça veut pas dire que tout
sera possible mais ça veut dire que les
montées sont très intéressés par ce qui
se passe dans leur ville ont beaucoup de
propositions à faire beaucoup de choses
à dire après il ya deux sujets qui me
tiennent à coeur particulièrement la
question du commerce ici on est en
centre ville mais il ya du commerce sur
l'ensemble de la ville donc il faut
qu'on est notre commerce de centre-ville
et notre commerce du val fourré aussi
j'y tiens beaucoup parce que le centre
commercial mans 2 2 est un lieu très
important il faut qu'on aide de façon
très précoce les enfants jeunes c'est
tous nos dispositifs d aide aux devoirs
et réussite éducative mais aussi qu'on
permette à ceux qui ont quitté le
système éducatif de reprendre des
formations et c'est pour ça que on a
proposé l'ouverture d'une école du
numérique pour remettre en formation des
jeunes qui apprennent un métier qu'ils
puissent retrouver le chemin de l'emploi
parmi les membres de la majorité
sortante en désaccord avec le maire
jean-luc santini avec la liste montrent
unis pour l'avenir avec lui huit
adjoints de la dernière majorité
repartent dans sa liste avec notamment
pierre bédier objectif s'inscrire dans
la continuité
en 2020 on a été élu sur un programme
on n'a pas bien compris justement
pourquoi le maire ne souhaitait pas à
appliquer le programme pour lequel on a
été on a été élu donc l'idée c'est bien
la continuité de ce programme les
dossiers prioritaires c'est le logement
bien sûr le logement puisque autant il y
a des problèmes au val fourré sur le
redémarrage du renouvellement urbain qui
est un petit peu en panne depuis des
années donc une priorité le
renouvellement urbain du val fourré mais
aussi le centre ville puis la sauvegarde
du commerce 1 qui qui va évidemment pas
très très bien comme vous n'en beaucoup
de villes mais à menton à on a l
ambition c'est d'avoir un commerce
dynamique autre liste portée par la
république en marche pour vous pour
mantes mené par françois gerber dans son
équipe des personnes de la société
civile des chefs d'entreprise novice en
politique ils veulent s'inscrire dans la
rupture on propose autre chose proposer
autre chose ça veut dire des gens
nouveaux qu'ils sont qui ne font pas
partie de des équipes sortantes le
logement parce que il y a
il ya une anormalité et une absence de
transparence dans l'affectation des
logements sociaux
l'écologie de terrain parce que la
perception écologique et là la
préoccupation écologique n'a jamais été
présentes de la part des élus sortants
et les écoles parce que les écoles
maternelles et primaires sont dans une
situation catastrophique au niveau
matériel ça c'est un truc qui nous
remontent des parents et des enseignants
à côté de ces listes classé à droite et
au centre trois listes sont classés à
gauche
[Musique]
dans les yvelines alors que les
tractations se poursuivent du côté de la
république en marché de la gauche pour
désigner les candidats aux élections
législatives les dés sont jetés pour les
républicains et son allié lui dei douze
candidats pour autant de
circonscriptions se présente sous
l'étiquette union pour les yvelines
battue en 2010 est pascal thévenot maire
de vélizy tentera de retrouver son poste
dans la 2e circonscription tandis
qu'alexandra dublanche vice présidente
de la région ile de france ou encore
anne cabri maire de la commune rurale
d'orson ville mène leur première
campagne respectivement dans la
cinquième et dixième circonscription
principale surprise l'absence de patrick
stefanini directeur de campagne de
valérie pécresse un temps pressenti dans
la 9e circonscription et qui finalement
cède sa place à paul in vino cours
lefebvre conseillère départementale
enfin les deux députés sortants michel
vialay dans la 8ème et philippe
benassaya dans la 11e tenteront de
conserver leur mandat le scrutin se
déroulera les 12 et 19 juin
[Musique]
bercy allonge la liste des biens russes
sous son contrôle en représailles à la
guerre qui se poursuit en ukraine 64
propriétés sont maintenant gelés en
france pour un total de 700 millions
d'euros et l'une d'entre elles se
trouvent dans les yvelines à saint léger
le château du clos est dirigé depuis
2018 par le fils d'un député de la douma
le parlement russe un ensemble composé
également de nombreux hectares est
estimé à plus de 11 millions d'euros des
informations rendues publiques ce mardi
par le ministère de l'économie
[Musique]
la noyade représentent la première cause
de décès par accidents chez les moins de
25 ans alors à la proche des grandes
vacances d'été les piscines des yvelines
redoublent d'efforts pour transmettre
les bons gestes dans l'eau
on essaie de les avertir et on sait
pertinemment tu sais très bien que la
noyade est dangereux on est d'accord les
accidents c'est toujours un pub est
malheureusement mais ça et ça arrive
c'est souvent un manque de vigilance de
la part des parents les enfants ils ont
conscience du danger ce jour j'en suis
persuadé
depuis la crise sanitaire le centre
aquatique propose des cours de
rattrapage durant les vacances scolaires
et certains enfants sont des habitués
dans la piscine on a pris 1
leur entraîneur de il ya là
nous après thomas de tenir la main sur
le voir
après
à les regarder le plafond étoilé
avec elle c'est très important bien sûr
rien
de s'informer revu entièrement gratuit
le stage dure une semaine et à la fin
chacun reçoit un diplôme nautique
garantissant ses aptitudes il ya
toujours une évolution cache au minimum
ouvrant d'autres il ya toujours une
évolution en fait et son chéri si
c'était un enfant qu'on nous comprenne
confiant sur la piscine qui sony
s'amuser ça les enfants ont bien compris
leur d'apprentissage se termine toujours
par un tour de toboggans
[Musique]
culture ans lille débutera dans quelques
jours pour sa 25e édition l'exposition
d'art contemporain de paris à andrésy
accueille onze artistes sur le thème de
l'envers du décor parmi eux laurent
perbos invité d'honneur l'artiste
plasticien utilise l'objet issus de la
grande consommation comme matière pour
ses oeuvres je vais prendre un objet qui
existe déjà et je vais en déformer une
caractéristique comme le poids la taille
ou la couleur pour que cet objet échappe
aux caractéristiques aux codes qu'on
al'habitude de la tribu et comme ses
prédécesseurs il a été invité à habiller
la façade de la maison du moussel
d'andrésy une flat à bol c'est une
oeuvre in situ réalisés sur place
spécialement pour le bâtiment elle a
nécessité près de quatre jours
d'installation et 150 gonflable de
tailles diverses je vais essayer de
donner l'illusion que le bâtiment
l'édifice est entièrement rempli de
gonflables et qu' il ya une telle
profusion que deux des fenêtres des
gonflables s'en échappe une oeuvre qui
propose deux lectures évocatrice de la
plage mais aussi critique d'une société
de surconsommation objectif questionner
le regard du spectateur au premier abord
assez gai ludique coloré joyeux et en
fait finalement si on regarde de plus
près c'est aussi très polluants ces
issues d'une industrie pétrochimique
avec un indice carbone
très élevé enfin bref voilà tout le tout
l'envers du propos que c'est censé au
premier abord véhiculer ce support une
opportunité pour l'artiste qui lui
permet de changer ses habitudes
effectivement c'est une belle
opportunité de pouvoir travailler sur un
sur un bâtiment comme ça d'une part ben
moi ça me permet de déplacer un peu mon
travail qui plutôt prend place dans des
galeries ou des centres d'art donc dans
des lieux un peu clos de murs blancs et
là c'est une réelle opportunité de
pouvoir un peu à être dans une démesure
sculptures en l'île débutera le 13 mai
prochain les oeuvres seront à découvrir
jusqu'au 25 septembre
[Musique]
encore un mot de culture pour saluer la
performance de déclic théâtre le club
d'improvisation de trappes vient de
décrocher le titre de vice-champion du
monde d'improvisation en suisse
catégorie junior de bonne augure avant
la prochaine édition de la compétition
qui se déroulera à trappes en février
2023 d'ici là la compagnie participera
le 10 mai au trophée d'improvisation
culture et diversité au conservatoire de
musique à trappes
[Musique]
originaire du royaume uni stéphanie
rambo est la première femme à la tête du
trianon palace un hôtel cinq étoiles
créée en 1910 emblème appliqué de la
ville de versailles une fierté pour la
nouvelle directrice générale cette scène
hôtel personnellement pour laquelle je
suis très attaché ça fait quelques
années que je travaille avec un jeune et
j'ai vu un petit peu cet hôtel dans le
contexte mon travail d'avants et c'était
toujours l'hôtel qui m'a passionné donc
évidemment très fier sa passion pour
l'hôtellerie elle la tient de son oncle
propriétaire de deux hôtels dans le nord
de l'angleterre elle y a débuté le
métier j'ai commencé mon travail dans
l'hôtellerie en angleterre dans des
forums fonctions
plus tôt dans la partie opérationnelle
j'ai rencontré longuement mari qui est
français après et en arrivant en france
c'était plutôt dans la partie
commerciale marketing
pour laquelle j'ai passé des années les
rênes de l'établissement versailles et
lui ont été confiées au mois de janvier
2022 et des responsabilités qui demande
beaucoup d'implication
c'est beaucoup de sens le détail et
quelque part c'est aussi un plaisir
beaucoup plus à l'âge est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus longue donc c'est vraiment
de se mettre dans les chaussures de nos
clients par rapport à ses attentes ses
besoins stéphanie rambo a déjà son
endroit préféré la suite terrasse pour
sa vue imprenable sur la ville et le
château de versailles donc là vous avez
devant vous une vue magnifique du
château de versailles évidemment vous
avez la ville a goûté sur votre côté
gauche et là vous avez toute la terre
vue du château de versailles voilà toute
la verdure devant vous également à long
terme la directrice générale souhaite
accroître le prestige de l'hôtel pour
l'heure elle prépare la haute saison le
waldorf astoria versailles trianon
palace est actuellement en train de
recruter et former les équipes pour
cette importante période à venir
[Musique]